an Indiana community is demanding
answers after recent testing revealed
toxic airborne contaminants in some
homes an environmental group in June
tested the air in 14 homes in Franklin
Indiana in six of the homes it found
three chemicals linked to cancer many
people there believe the contamination
has led to more pediatric cancer cases
in the area only on CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz spoke with two moms leading
the push for answers we used our kids as
the canary in the coal mine in our town
for Johnson County mother Cary Reinhardt
this cause is deeply personal in 2014
her 13 year old daughter Emma was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
brain cancer just three months later she
died to say that I'm angry is an
understatement I feel like I owe Emma to
figure out what's going on Reinhardt
teamed up with fellow mom Stacy Davidson
her stepson Zane was diagnosed with
leukemia in 2014 she and Reinhardt
started an organization called if it was
your child together they've tracked
dozens of pediatric cancer cases in
their area they believe they have enough
to be considered a cancer cluster after
Zane was diagnosed there were nine
children in 16 months diagnosed in the
county how was your first day of school
Davidson says Zane is one of the lucky
ones after three years of treatment
he's now in remission at least seventy
nine children in Johnson County have
been diagnosed with a rare form of
cancer in the last ten years more than a
quarter of those who were in the town of
Franklin alone but state health
officials told the moms there weren't
enough cancer cases to be considered a
cluster we've been told constantly that
there's no problem it's just a
coincidence
it's bad luck but in 2015 they learned
about a decade's old manufacturing site
where the EPA says toxic chemicals
leaked into the environment in the 1990s
the EPA had the company who bought the
land later Amphenol removed contaminated
soil a contaminated sewer system and
install a pump to remove toxic chemicals
including TCE which the EPA linked
to cancer contaminants don't you know
see signs or see roads and say oh I'll
stop here
Shannon Lisa and Bob Spiegel from the
nonprofit Edison wetlands Association
recently tested the air quality in 14
homes near the former Amphenol site six
tested high for toxins one home and one
outdoor area had levels of TCE
that were more than 18 times Indiana's
corrective action level just the street
separating them there's evidence that
there are potential impacts to these
residential areas far beyond a problem
that the agencies had ever really
explored before some say health and
environmental officials have denied
there's a problem that's why it's
important to voice their concerns at a
recent community meeting I want you to
tell us how you specifically are going
to be more engaged than the people that
were here three years ago and just
patted us on the head and told us to be
quiet we want transparency and we want
honesty for our town at the meeting
state health officials said they've
evaluated cancer numbers and 2015 and
2017 but closed their investigations
when they determined a cancer cluster
did not exist now they say they'll
partner with the CDC to further
investigate so they're actually going to
go back and evaluate all the work that
we've done in the past with regards to
the cancer registry the state's
Department of Environmental Management
offered to retest two of the homes that
tested high for TCE back in the 90s that
we did our sampling we investigated the
site they said they're working out an
action plan for the former Amphenol site
this is kind of starting a little bit
from scratch but using the information
we had in the past about where the
contamination was found my stepson went
through three and a half years of
treatment of he'll Davidson and Reinhart
want the EPA to do comprehensive testing
in the city of Franklin and they say
nothing will stop them our key phrase
right now is not one more not one more
child should have to go through what our
kids have gone through they mess with
the two wrong ones for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz Johnson County Indiana
there's some strong and angry mothers
well the Amphenol corporation which
owned the land after operations on the
property had ended says it's been
working with the EPA on this for years
it recently conducted a
additional ambient air testing and found
the results met EPA standards the EPA
says it's working with the company on
further testing and the Indiana
Department of Environmental Management
is considering putting a permanent air
monitoring system in Franklin the
mother's we spoke to want hundreds of
local homes tested and when you hear
that story you can understand why